[Applause]
[Music]
i've had
enough for too long this subreddit
has been beaten by me irl
proclaims to be the only good son
pewdiepie's separation only good
subreddit
what the [ __ ] is this i will review you
and then i'll take your soul
oh my god it's me isn't it
no i'm sorry i'm sorry
god damn it me building up the courage
to unsubscribe from a youtuber who i
watch
grow and progressively become more and
more annoying oh my god
this is the most passive aggressive
thing i've ever seen i don't even know
that was the highest voted what the [ __ ]
dude
control f pewdiepie let's go oh hell
yeah
oh hell yeah that's right i'm not
annoying
[Music]
we still got it bros is that chad meme
pewdiepie is annoying i know i know
students at you didn't reflect college
of pharmacy have developed the chemical
compound
that kills brain cancer cells they have
also refined it to ignore brain
healthy brain tissue and focus on the
cancer cells make this go viral before
it suddenly doesn't exist
11 months ago i never heard about it
again i think it worked
damn they get a lot up votes what the
[ __ ] is this subreddit
people who treat their birthday as a
normal day think they're more mature
than everyone
we're just miserable
no i'm not laughing at this subreddit
it's funny because it's true
starting a fight consoling a child
petting a dog hey buddy
but what are the orange green and purple
ones yeah right what are those
consoling a child and petting a dog
purple shushing noises
petting a dog nah doesn't work come on
orange do you want to go outside
starting a fight again
that's funny green you want to call your
mommy
starting a fight because
all right yeah that was pretty
chuckle-worthy and laughed i
didn't chuckle i didn't laugh at all how
most people see america
stupid idiots cowboy stupid idiot
florida's trash
idiots stupid idiots stupid idiots
respect okay no it goes like this
especially dumb [ __ ] cowboy
people i don't know what they want nuke
this area i'm just kidding i'm just
joking
all right uh doctors will be like go and
buy this
and the pharmacist will give it to you
this signature looks legitimate
we were trying too hard to force
signatures as kids who would have
thought you just needed a line
yeah i i remember i was so confused
in first grade in school i was five
years old and i learned that we needed
our parents signature on the paper and i
was like
wait but they just write it and they're
like yeah that's how we identify that
it's real i'm like
but anyone can write it
and i still can't make sense of it you
think with a digital age there'd be
an encrypt version to at least sign
something or i don't know something more
legitimate but no we're
we're doing signatures that's uh the
best we can do
oh actually we do have uh in sweden it's
called like bank id or something
maybe you guys have it as well it's like
an electronic signature
never mind sweden invented it you're
welcome
tigers have false eyes on the back of
their ears
to discourage predators from attacking
them from behind i'm slightly less
terrified of tigers now
and a thousand more terrified or
whatever the [ __ ] a tiger considers a
predator
yeah right what would attack a tiger
deer when a branch cranks
dear when two turns of steel
kilometers per hour and can i just say a
special shout out to this mia
you know what i like to subreddit
because they don't use freaking american
metrics
or british miles per hours kilometers
kilometers per hour
kilometers [ __ ] this gets an up
vote for me and i never uploaded
anything on another subreddit
me rl maybe you we're not so different
you and i health experts please wear
protective suits in space
americans can't stop me
from wearing my goddamn rats smile i
can't breathe in the suit
man i can't breathe with this wearing
this the carbon dioxide
gets recycled man i ain't doing it it's
my right it's my goddamn rap
me when i suddenly forgot a word in my
native language but i know
it in english oh my god why can't i
relate to this subreddit so much
it's so annoying oh my god i'm
pleasantly surprised
heartbreaking man too good at fighting
game to enjoy playing against friends
but not good enough to play
competitively
[Music]
what the hell this is so relatable too
it's like you suck all the fun out
if you're playing with friends and you
don't want to be that person but you're
nowhere near good enough when you play
online against really good people
doing this without any reason oh my god
it's important
i remember when i was harbor captain we
always have the
thing from boats what are they called in
english i don't know you all
you have to spin them around in a snake
circle otherwise you're not a goddamn
sailor god damn it
the vikings did it before us and the
cave vikings did it before
them he didn't just group up he flipping
glow up
that's beautiful well done
[Laughter]
scientists then we cloned the sheep yes
we will discover life in space soon yes
we we will find hiv cure we have a robot
on mars
scientists now no the earth is not
flat seriously your kid will not die
[ __ ] sake wherever
yes the mood is real
what yeah what the [ __ ] happened with
all these skeptics and dumbasses
the internet gave them a platform that's
what happened before they were just that
weirdo in the garage
wait what if i walk into a girl's house
and she got like 50 plants i know she's
a keeper because she already takes care
of a bunch of useless
what's one more that's a good point but
planes are annoying
so this is a downward for me i'm sorry
when a plane's ever done
anything for me huh i suspect take care
of you what do you do for me huh
nothing you worthless the worst pain is
having a nice ass
oh meal in front of you but what's with
all the
butt puns you can't find a good youtube
video to watch while you eat
oh my god yes and then the food gets
colder
and colder and colder and the pain seeps
in in
every moment you don't know pain
until you let the heat fade i am once
again
asking you to wear a mask very good meme
bernard thank you
yeah like by taking precautions speaking
of which
you can get the mask right now on
represent.com besides pewdiepie
but don't forget like you're not just
preventing
the meme mean virus you're preventing
all viruses
there are more than one remember like
it's a precaution
that i think in general we should be
using anyway so i don't see the whole
art see edgar can even wear one
damn you look cool as hell dude man
chokes his dog oh he's so
cute look at he can't see oh you can't
see he's so
cute let's clean the house today no
okay a day of relaxing it is no relaxing
only guilt
what you gotta do is you gotta turn off
your phone and do not check it
before you take a break because if you
know that there's something in the back
of your mind that you need to do you
cannot take a break so the key
is don't check your phone as often
that's how you relax like a goddamn pro
what you don't know can't hurt you and
what you don't know probably
can wait a little bit it'll be fine wait
i am your world
bro oh which hair's been oh we got some
cringe here
it's 24 days old but yeah that's a
download for me sir
that's funny uh me losing my mom at the
grocery store at 22 years of age
images you can actually hear a european
waking up early
a new problem in the u.s accurate
scientifically proven stay retired paul
you're a better commentator than fighter
does it make you feel good saying that
now would you say that to my face man of
maine nope you'd kick my ass that's why
i said it on twitter
fair enough he's got a point
know you've been already for too long
when this looks normal this looks
weird i've never seen that what the [ __ ]
is that
that makes no sense isn't that funny in
gear
does it make you laugh you know look at
it look at the name
look at the meme okay you're making me
angry
line up in alphabetical order aaron
aaron there's no aaron is there air
i'm confused i just bought a 400 000
house
ohio california yeah
[Laughter]
this man or woman who made this clearly
not swedish don't you know you just have
to say the original
prophecy anthem you just have to play
the tambourine and it will assemble
itself
hey remember that meme from the
beginning i'm sorry don't unsubscribe
please
don't let go when microsoft word puts in
a red squiggly line under your last name
the day i lost my identity
yeah it used to be a thing with
pewdiepie but now he doesn't do it
anymore
that's right look at that just no
no there we go there we go that's better
apparently what the [ __ ]
a 45 minute nap should set me straight
four hours later
oh long have i
been asleep three thousand years i'm an
adult i need to confront my
responsibilities
also me
[Music]
did it
oh that sucks rosie
well you tried that's better than not it
feels like me when i'm dreading to do a
task
and then it takes like half a half a
minute to complete it
like whoa like if i if i know i have to
do my emails and then
because i know there's a lot of them but
then i actually go through them like
wait that took
that took five minutes seriously i've
been postponing that
why didn't i just do it i'm surprised
that americans still don't have their
own univ
of time so they don't don't tell them
this is what i said in the last video
and i stand by it americans
shut the [ __ ] up about your metrics all
right get a unit of time already
it's getting cringy introverts preparing
to say here during
attendance
oh man
why there's so many good memes i've
never seen god damn it
i had this weird character trait where i
hate myself but still think i'm better
than everyone else
because you're your own worst critic
it's because you realize that you're not
actually better than you're anyone else
you just like to think that you are and
that's what makes you hate yourself bro
bro just relax we're all gonna die it's
okay you don't have to try so hard
just found out the average dream lasts
two to three seconds
bruh i'll be going on a whole as
missions
i've been doing it what the [ __ ] no that
actually makes sense to me
whenever i have lucy dreams it's so hard
to stay on track for longer
at least that makes sense to me at least
you know when you can control your own
dreams because you're self-aware of it
i'm always like alright so i know you're
self-aware of it
but make sure you focus on what you want
and look at so that you can get the goal
focus on the yo-yo championship winning
tournament focus on it
focus on it but it never lasts more than
two to three seconds it's really
annoying
waiters sir the food is is free for
children under 10.
dad oh that's great because he recently
turned nine but dad
i'm twin why do kids do that
what a little [ __ ]
hearing my voice in my head versus
hearing my voice on recordings
all right i got a last chuckle out
that's me irl
everyone do not i repeat do not
subscribe to this subreddit
because they're at 4.2 and you you don't
want to mess with that
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed subscribe check out mask be
protected
show everyone your pee pee here and
that's all for me
for now hey dog
[Music]
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean